bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition us 7,8 ce week-end
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs à vos
idées de sorties dans ce magazine nous
parlerons des clés si belle le grand
rendez vous musical du département
organisé aux clayes-sous-bois pour nous
parler de cet événement nous recevrons
sur ce plateau dans quelques instants
benjamin ball ans le co organisateur du
festival nous feront également le point
sur les manifestations musicales qui
seront programmées tout au long du
week-end dans le département pour la
fête de la musique
enfin coup de projecteur dans cette
édition sur les différents rendez vous
sportifs du week-end au département il y
aura du rugby avec le tournoi 17 cauet
coeur de la course à pied avec la course
royal de versailles et du tir à l'arc à
guyancourt mais tout de suite place à
notre premier invité je vous le disais
dans les titres le festival etc les
sybelles est programmée ce samedi 20
juin de 16 heures à minuit au parc de
dialoguer sous bois pour nous parler de
cet événement nous recevons sur ce
plateau benjamin ball en co organisateur
du festival bonjour bonjour alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter ce
festival le festival des clés si belle
existe depuis 1988 c'est un mélange
entre deux grandes stars de la chanson
et puis les artistes locaux et pourquoi
avoir choisi le parc de diane c'est
vraiment le lieu adapté c'est très
nature c'est voilà c'est à la fois le
lieu adapté c'est un magnifique parc et
puis c'est aussi le lieu historique de
la ville des clayes-sous-bois et vous
vend le festival été créé en 1988 est ce
que le public de 1988 a évolué est-ce
qu'il est plus exigeant est ce qu'ils
réclament d'autres tête d'affiche oui là
le public a évolué comme la société mais
enfin on reste quand même sur un public
très familial puisque dès 15 heures il
ya aussi une programmation pour les
enfants et leurs parents donc on
accueille vraiment un public venu de
tout les yvelines et qui reste familiale
et leur public pour toujours présent ah
oui c'était un gros festival c'était à
la fois les les clés siens avec les
siennes viennent nombreux et ils ont
aussi plaisir à accueillir les gens qui
viennent de toutes les yvelines
comment une personne viennent chaque
année alors suivant la météo m'ont là
demain les annonces du très beau temps
mais on est on est toujours au dessus de
8000 et puis on peut monter jusqu'à
15000 personnes et est ce que vous vous
présentez un petit peu la programmation
cette année y aura de grosses têtes
d'affiché on peut le dire bien sûr alors
bien sûr yannick noah et ben l'oncle
soul 1
et j'ai avant donc les wackids qui sont
à un groupe en direction des enfants et
de leurs parents
et puis après des artistes locaux aux
pirates zone aulas il a une elle cote
rmila et comment on les fait venir
justement c'était deux affiches
moi je pense que le festival des clés si
belle commence à avoir une belle
notoriété donc il est de plus en plus
facile de les faire venir
voilà et puis c'est vrai que c'est un
c'est un lieu qui est quand même
agréable et jouer devant 15000 personnes
c'est toujours un plaisir et vous le
disais il ya également des artistes
locaux en plus des têtes d'affiché comme
yannick noah ou ben l'oncle soul
il ya des artistes locaux c'est aussi ça
l'objectif de propulser des clés siens
sur le devant de la scène
bien sûr parce que toute l'année on fait
aussi des scènes ouvertes où les groupes
peuvent peuvent jouer devant l'ecc les
siens et au fil de l'année on en
sélectionne qui sont donc choisi pour
jouer en première partie aux clés si
belle les choristes ont sélectionné le
restaurant c'est un juriste un jury à la
fois composé d'habitants d'élus et de
professionnels qui voient là je
sélectionne quelques quelques groupes
qui ont le privilège de jouer entend
bien parti et on remarque également
qu'il y a enfin on peut dire que que ces
chanteurs et il revient de chaque année
est ce que est ce que au final
au final ils sont heureux de venir jouer
ici vous disait qu'il y avait quinze
mille personnes
moi je pense que oui l'ambiance du parc
de diagne et ressentent comme en fait au
final de ce festival à on a on n'a
jamais eu de gens qui ressorte est déçu
je pense que l'ambiance du parc de diane
est maintenant connue et reconnue
est ce que ce festival sera reconduit
est ce que est ce que c'est un festival
qui doit perdurer dans le temps je pense
je pense que les clés sienne et que les
siennes sont très attachés à leur
festival et en plus je pense qu'ils
prennent un grand plaisir à accueillir
aussi voilà les visiteurs des autres
villes des yvelines
et est ce que
l'année prochaine il ya peut-être des
aides affiche que vous aimeriez avoir
sur le festival
alors ça ça reste le secret parce qu'on
dévoile sa vraiment à la dernière minute
mais maintenant les clés si belle c'est
souvent tous les deux ans voilà donc on
prépare d'ores et déjà la prochaine
édition ça c'est sûr merci beaucoup
benjamin ball ans mercy dépasser sur ce
plateau je le rappelle le festival etc
les sybelles est programmée ce samedi de
16h à minuit aux clayes-sous-bois coup
de projecteur maintenant sur la fête de
la musique dans le département
ce dimanche 21 juin ce sera la fête de
la musique comme chaque année des
manifestations sont programmées dans
tout le département
coup de projecteur sur les principaux
rendez-vous xavier jaglin pour le
montage à magny les hameaux fête de la
musique autour du cristal baschet avec
l'ensemble de william byrd ce dimanche
entre 15h et 17h au musée de port royal
des champs
une soirée organisée par l'association
pour le rayonnement de port-royal
concert à retrouver également la veille
le samedi à 21h suivi d'un feu
d'artifice à elancourt au rendez vous
dimanche à 17 heures à la maison de
quartier de la ville dieu
la chorale crescendo vous convie à la
fête de la musique c'est gratuit la fête
de la musique se conjugue à trappes avec
la fête de la ville des concerts de
groupes locaux seront proposés à partir
de 17 heures point fort de cette soirée
le concert de sinsemilia 21h38 d'un feu
d'artifice que peut-on vous souhaiter
tout le bonheur du monde
quelqu'un peut il même maire de calmont
jardin
je souhaite tout le bonheur du monde
pour aujourd'hui comme pour vos mains de
votre soleil éclaire six longues qui
brille
amour au quotidien
à maurepas le rendez vous est fixé ce
samedi à l'est de la côte d'or les
élèves du conservatoire de musique et
d'art dramatique se produiront de 10h à
10h30 puis les choeurs de la pléiade de
10h45 à 11 heures et encore le coeur
près chendo de 11h à 12h pour la
première fois la ville de bois d'arcy
organise la fête de la musique à la fin
de la tramblais ce samedi concert à
partir de 15h30 pour les plus jeunes dès
6 ans avec les courtes pattes
à noter à 20h45 le concert des killers
et à partir de 21h30 un battle entre les
amateurs des rolling stones et les
beatles l'entrée est libre
d'autres dates à noter également dans
vos agendas à guyancourt la date du
samedi a été choisie pour marquer la
fête fête de la musique autour de la
batterie en intérieur ou en extérieur un
programme a été mis en place pour
mélanger les différents styles
il y aura du rock de la pop du métal du
blues et du gospel et des chorales
la soirée commence à 18 heures et se
terminera aux alentours de minuit à
voisins le bretonneux place aux groupes
locaux qui vont se partager 300 devant
l'espace musique à la grange aux sons et
dans la cour de covile ce sera dimanche
à partir de 16h une programmation qui
mêle le classique et des groupes du
collectif mais ta sauce la soirée
commence dès 16 heures avec un concert
d'éric denis müller au piano à verser à
versailles divers un podium seront
installés de la place du marché notre
dame dans la place de la cathédrale
saint louis ce dimanche de 18h à minuit
au parking de l'europe il y aura de
l'électro créative avenue de paris ce
soir de la techno du reggae pour la
venue de sochaux et enfin du pop rock à
la place de la cathédrale saint louis
enfin à montigny-le-bretonneux la fête
de la musique comment ce dimanche à 16
heures au château de la coudre une fête
de la musique qui sera placée sous le
signe de la musique amplifiée
l'événement sera bien évidemment gratuit
non sur le musée lambinet de versailles
nous poursuivons ce magazine par un
rendez vous à ne pas manquer jusqu'à ce
dimanche au musée lambinet de versailles
propose une exposition singulière
les artistes sont tous atteints de
troubles psychiques des oeuvres qui
dégage une force étrange puissante
coloré expressive sont les oeuvres des
neuf artistes de l'exposition confluence
présentée au musée lambinet jusqu'au 21
juin
souffrant de troubles psychiques ces
artistes nous offrent une vision du
monde
intense et parfois en rupture avec la
société
comme au travers des ciseaux de virginie
debussy ou de la sorcière de karen j'ai
exprimé une chose personnelle
la sorcière par exemple qui est basé sur
un autre portrait qu'elle a une place
dans la société en fait quand même si
elle est un peu mise à mal par enfant
parent par des préjugés qui combat par
rapport au personnage de la force un
moment incertain c'est un personnage qui
peut faire peur pour vous dessins
peintures photographies sculptures et
vidéos sont autant de supports travaillé
au cours de la résidence artistique
précédent l'exposition les artistes sont
alors guidés dans leur travail toujours
invités à le terminer et bénéficient de
conseils de professionnels où on
travaille auprès d'eux ça a été parfois
d'apporter un peu de technique des
touches technique utilisée le bloquer ou
parfois des références artistiques pour
leur permettre de rebondir quand ils ces
chiens au peu sur des idées les
encourager la finir quand il avait des
petits moments un couple baby kg arrivé
derrière et je leur ai un peu trop porté
un peu l'énergie que parfois ils
n'avaient pas la force de trouver eux
mêmes tous ont ce qui m'a beaucoup
frappé c'est leur capacité à créer
rapidement et tout de suite parce que la
plupart très sincèrement en une séance
une oeuvre est sa vraie chance en
remarquant cette résidence artistique a
été organisée d'octobre à mai sous la
forme d'ateliers hebdomadaires qui en
plus d'être source d'inspiration se sont
révélés pour les artistes bien souvent
libérateur oui c'est libérateur à mesure
où on pense à ces peut donc ça libère
c'est ça libère ne pas trop penser à soi
permet quand même de le canaliser pas
mal ses émotions se concentrant mais en
ce concentrant d'une bonne manière
c'est-à-dire sans vraiment qui est de
penser qu'ils viennent interrompre le
travail donc ces choses très très
efficace donner de la visibilité à ces
artistes singuliers souffrant de
troubles psychiques et leur faire vivre
une véritable expérience professionnelle
en
danse artistique et tout l'enjeu de
l'association art convergence chaque
année organise une nouvelle exposition
la commune de train pas organise ce
samedi de midi à 23h15 une nouvelle
édition de la ville en fête pour nous
parler de cet événement nous recevons
sur ce plateau philippe guy roux adjoint
au maire délégué à la culture aux fêtes
et aux cérémonies bonjour monsieur
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter cet événement ah oui alors
sous son aspect agenda ou son aspect
plus organisationnel sur son agenda vous
le dites 1 c2 de midi jusqu'au soir ça
ira plus loin que 23 heures puisque l'on
aura le feu d'artifice qui j'espère nous
amènera jusqu'à minuit jusqu au 21 juin
qui annoncera la fais de la musique dont
vous parlais tout à l'heure et vous
attendez combien de personnes sur 7
alors en fait c'est un moment très
attendu par les trappistes toute l'année
on attend cette fête qui qui se veut en
fait un moment d'union de la ville à un
moment de reconquête du bien vivre
ensemble chose qui est une priorité pour
nous pour ce mandat et pour les mandats
d'avant bien sûr est ce que l'on
souhaite cette année on a voulu changer
de modèle de formule 2 formule on va
dire et puisque c'était vraiment un
souhait des populations et des
associations de nous dire on voudrait
être au coeur de cet événement et on
voudrait que les quartiers aux portes
cette fête est donc on avait une formule
où tout se passait avant au stade
travaux et cette année cette nouvelle
formule partira du parc des bateleurs à
côté d'eux le md donc l'école de musique
et de danse pour aller ensuite jusqu'au
stade gravaud nous nous attendre des
grands concerts c'est un événement qui
est ouvert à tout le monde on retrouve
absolument à tout le monde
j'entendais aussi tout à l'heure par les
dons des clés si belle ou des autres
festivals en fin de compte on se
comporte comme au festival cette année
puisqu'on va avoir des animations toute
la journée on se retrouvera le soir avec
une pré fête de la musique et que tous
les les artistes on les appelle nous les
trappes artistes tous les jeunes
musiciens et moins jeunes musiciens qui
viendront sur des grosses grosses scènes
ce que pour nous c'est important de leur
donner les moyens de jouer sur des
grosses grosses scènes et ils seront les
relayé ensuite par le concert on les
avait tout talent aussi en intro des
sinsemilia qui nous apporteront j'espère
tout le bonheur du monde
et quels sont tous les artistes qui
seront présents pendant cette journée
alors on a eu au début de
de la journée plutôt de l'animation de
ville puisque les artistes vont
présenter un petit peu leurs habitudes
comment ils peignent donc il y aura une
fraise qui sera organisée on va avoir en
or aussi avec les services de la ville
les associations sportives de la ville
des animations sur le sport sur le judo
ddd des mots comme ça qui seront faites
un peu partout sur tout un parcours et
donc on ira comme ça de lieux en lieux
avec une une déambulation finale aux
alentours de 18 heures retrouvez cet
espace convivial qu'est le stade gravaud
ouvert à tout le monde est gratuit et
gratuitement attention c'est un
magnifique concert également retrouver
les espaces de de restauration qui se
veulent aussi est un lieu unique où tout
le monde pourra manger ensemble à partir
de 20h de même 19 heures je pense les
vous disais le soir il y aura le concert
le fameux concert de sinsemilia c'est ça
c'est vraiment le point d'orgue
c'est le point d'orgue parce
qu'effectivement c'est une musique
festive une musique engagée aussi sont
des gens qui ont été capables de nous
appeler quand on a vécu les tristes les
tristes événements du 1er mai ce sont
des gens qui nous ont appelés pour nous
dire mais écoutez on est très heureux de
venir on vous soutient on est avec vous
donc en fait ce ne sont pas des
trappistes mais ce pourrait être des
enfants de trappes aussi donc voilà le
point d'orgue pour moi c'est
effectivement la totalité de la journée
parce que on a souhaité remettent les
associations les populations au milieu
au coeur du dispositif et je pense que
tout le monde va saluer tout le monde va
faire la fête et c'est un privilège de
recevoir sensini là sur ce type
d'événement
ah oui c'est un privilège c'est s'éteint
c'est un groupe qui a durement pendant
plusieurs mois pour le faire venir
je pense qu'ils ont été sensibles à
notre ville je pense que la volonté
d'animer une ville comme comme la nôtre
une ville qui s'est toujours battu pour
sa culture une ville qui met les moyens
qui place la culture comme une priorité
qui place la jeunesse comme une priorité
je pense qu'ils ont été sensibles à ça
et ça n'a pas été si difficile que ça et
vous le disais la soirée se clôturera
par un gigantesque feu d'artifice
voilà donc en fait on va pouvoir voir
notre ciel s'illuminer de toutes les
couleurs c'est aussi une particularité
un attrape d'avoir toutes ses couleurs
de tous les jours on le voit sur les
marchés etc
donc c'est aussi le symbole d'un monde
voilà la liberté où on va laisser
exploser notre joie à laisser partir
dans le ciel ça sera avec une belle
musique synchronisée je crois que nous
ont préparé un truc assez assez
impressionnant cette année ce sera
évidemment dès qu'il fait nuit c'est aux
alentours de 23h15 23h30 habituellement
et c'est je pense que ça peut attirer
beaucoup de monde ce sera magnifique ce
soir et en 30 secondes est ce que vous
pouvez nous donner envie de venir
voilà cet événement en 30 secondes bah
oui j'appelle de toutes les familles à
venir passer du temps à venir pour les
petits manèges occuper leurs enfants
pour les plus âgés venir s'essayer à la
danse à la zumba aux sports venir voir
ces groupes de musique qui valent
vraiment la peine il ya un vrai vrai
talent sur trappe qui qui est
aujourd'hui à au coeur de la culture de
trappes et puis effectivement rentré
dans ce stade delle un festival or on
n'est que sur une fête de ville moi je
trouve ça merveilleux je trouve que
c'est encore un très très beau travail
des services et est encore une fois la
municipalité est derrière moi pour
soutenir cette opération
merci philippe bigard ou merci et
j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de monde
pour cette nouvelle édition la ville en
fête et j'espère que le soleil sera au
rendez vous pour ce feu d'artifice
ah oui on lance à devrait aller on l'a
connu la météo ça devrait aller au delà
comme on passe maintenant à notre
rubrique exposition
une exposition celle de rémi mayer à
rambouillet le palais du roi de rome
consacre une exposition à l'art de la
laque à savoir faire ancestral qui
devient de plus en plus rares katherine
hull à tous
spécialiste de la laque de chine depuis
35 ans et ancien styliste pour de grands
noms de la mode
rémy maillard expose ses peintures et
sculptures aux baleines du roi de rome à
rambouillet
mais des corps ont évolué par rapport à
la haute couture
bien sûr qu'on ressent des réminiscences
les kimonos en son expression j'aimais
beaucoup les étoffes j'aimais beaucoup
la soie mais lorsque j'ai découvert la
lacc
c'est à travers le lac je me suis
exprimé une grande créativité qui fait
voyager les visiteurs dans une technique
ancestrale issus de métiers existants en
chine et au japon depuis des millénaires
ces procédés et son art ont beaucoup
évolué en ce qui concerne donc les les
bases ou les supports qui sont utilisés
dans la laque
traditionnellement c'est surtout le bois
qui est préférée chez les lakers est un
matériau qu'on peut transformer que l'on
peut occulter que l'on peut façonner
j'utilise aussi c'est de la fibre de
verre depuis quelques années parce que
la fibre de verre pourquoi parce qu'elle
est très légère
rémy maillard incruste dans ses oeuvres
entre autres des coquilles d'oeuf de
cahiers de l'anacr un espace didactique
montre par le biais de vidéos comment
ces oeuvres sont exécutés des créations
contemporaines et sensuelle mais aussi
spirituelle et symbolique
j'utilise beaucoup la symbolique dans
mes oeuvres et elle essaye surtout ces
deux des levées de sortir de la matière
leur regard d'un ce ne sont pas des
pauses des oeuvres posé ce sont 17 une
exposition qui a été construite au fil
de l'exposition l'artiste a voulu créer
un sentiment d'intention vers la lumière
avec les escaliers les oeuvres passe
ainsi du plus sombre plus clair un
travail ardu et minutieux auquel
l'artiste a consacré cinq années avant
de pouvoir présenter son savoir-faire à
découvrir jusqu'au 30 août
c'est une tradition dans le 7-8 week-end
comme tous les vendredis nous demandons
le coup de coeur d'un professionnels du
7e art
on prend aujourd'hui la direction des
clayes-sous-bois avec le programateur à
cyril haddad
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film le labyrinthe du silence l'action
se déroule en allemagne en 1958 un jeune
procureur découvre des pièces
essentielles permettant l'ouverture d'un
procès contre d'anciens ss ayant servi à
auschwitz mais il doit faire face à de
nombreuses aux hostilités dans cette
allemagne d'après guerre déterminé il
fera tout pour que les allemands ne suis
pas leur passé le labyrinthe du silence
est inspiré de l'histoire vraie de fritz
bauer procureur général de francfort et
de trois procureurs travaillant pour lui
qui furent à l'origine du procès est
vite qui se déroula dans les années 60
réalisé avec passion et conviction ce
film est d'autant plus impressionnant
qu'il s'agit d'un premier long métrage
formellement maîtrisé à travers une
reconstitution soignée
le cinéaste réussit un vrai tour de
force en présentant ce récit méconnus
comme un thriller palpitant
il s'en sort remarquablement bien en ne
filmant aucune reconstitution des camps
et des exactions commises le labyrinthe
du silence est proposé en version
originale cette semaine à l'espace
subissent nos rêves
c'est à lui que ce choix et les enfants
après le cinéma on passe maintenant au
théâtre
nous poursuivons ce magazine avec le 16e
championnat inter collèges de théâtre
d'improvisation organisé à part la
compagnie déclic théâtre
les finales se sont déroulées à la
merise de trappes quatre collèges
étaient concernés courbet le village
attrape alexandre dumas à maurepas et
avec albert einstein à magny les hameaux
un reportage de mélanie poker c'est
toujours une réussite
effectivement c'était d'une part aux
partenaires qui nous aident depuis de
très nombreuses années s'est lui aussi à
l'activité des collègues donc
enseignants qui font un boulot énorme
et puis c'est bien aussi à déclic
théâtre suisse air de pouvoir le gars là
en championnat avec une formule qui a
fait ses preuves avant de passer dans la
patinoire les jeunes de quatre collèges
de l'agglomération découvre les thèmes
imposés par larbitre un arbitre exigeant
qui distribue bons et mauvais points
le public et lui invité à voter pour
choisir la meilleure prestation et les
collégiens ont été bien formé par leur
coach c'était assez stressé mais du coup
on a on a privilégié le fait que c'était
une rencontre plus qu'une finale
puisqu'un match et du coup ils se sont
détendus au fur et à mesure ils ont ils
ont réussi à créer le partage dans les
improvisations dans l'imaginaire et du
coup bah voilà ils ont su montrer leur
talent dans la patinoire avec les autres
et pas contre les autres en finale le
collège le village l'emportent face à
l'équipe d'albert einstein de magny les
hameaux des étoiles ont aussi récompensé
les meilleurs joueurs de manière
individuelle
ça s'est très bien passé on a
il a joué malgré des petites tensions
parce que voilà avant tout ses
spectacles à du monde 300 personnes un
peu le trac et tout ça mais sinon
globalement ça s'est bien passé
qu'est ce que tu vas retenir toi
qu'est-ce que tu vas retenir de cette
finale ben là par la victoire ben la
victoire c'était génial on peu déçu de
ne pas avoir gagné mais c'est quand même
bien d'être arrivé deuxième alors
qu'est-ce que tu retiendras de cette
soirée il y avait des peines
improvisation comme il y avait des très
belles improvisations est bon on avait
des très bons adversaires en phase donc
je suis pas étonné qu'ils aient gagné
mais j'espère qu'on gagnera l'année
prochaine donc toi c'est déjà là les
prochains rendez-vous en 2016 ouais
c'est ça et c'est benoît hamon le député
socialiste de la 11e circonscription de
trappes qui a remis le premier prix à
l'équipe gagnante
qui s'est construit imaginer attrape il
ya maintenant c'est le 16e championnat
intercollèges va être déployé dans
l'éducation nationale dans le cadre de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires chez
les tout-petits donc en primaire ce qui
montre que on a compris qu'avec ce genre
de prestation là et des gamins qui
pouvait avoir des difficultés dans les
cours classiques qui déverrouille des
choses par le théâtre par
l'improvisation une soirée aussi bien
techniques que divertissante sur fond de
reprise musicale et d'éclats de rire on
commence cette page sports part du rugby
en battant l'équipe de l'entente racing
métro nanterre sur le score de 56 à 12
les cadets du sky rugby se sont
qualifiés pour la finale de la coupe
ile-de-france les saint quentinois sont
opposés au rugby club du plateau briard
la rencontre est programmée ce dimanche
21 juin au stade éric durand à viry
châtillon
la rencontre est ouverte à tous les
spectateurs toujours en rugby la
quatrième édition du tournoi 7 de coeur
est programmée ce samedi dimanche au
stade porsche centaines de versailles de
10h à 20h les meilleures équipes de
rugby à sept françaises et étrangères
seront présentes pour ce beau rendez
vous en parallèle de la manifestation un
tournoi de dodgeball équivalent de la
balle au prisonnier de ventre glisse
seront organisées l'objectif est de
récolter un maximum de dons en faveur de
l'association caritative
on passe à la course à pied la fameuse
course royal est programmée ce dimanche
à partir de 9 heures au château de
versailles
plus de 500 personnes se sont inscrites
pour participer à cette course de 15 km
l'une des particularités de cette
épreuve reste le terrain il se déroule
sur un terrain mixte sur la de la route
et de la pelouse mais également sur du
pavé imaginez le traumatisme pour les
jambes sports extrêmes à présent
l'inauguration du skatepark de
montilliers bretonne est organisée ce
samedi à partir de 14 heures au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin
au programme une dizaine d'animations
les jeunes et les moins jeunes pourront
tester un tremplin airbag du bmx et de
la trottinette un tournoi sera également
organisée avec une remise de récompenses
si vous voulez assister à l'événement
l'accès est libre 1 enfin une dernière
date à noter dans vos agendas ce
week-end il y aura du tir à l'arc au
gymnase des droits de l'homme à
guyancourt mady's baptisé le tir du roy
la compétition regroupera une centaine
d'archers venus de toute l'île de france
les épreuves en extérieur concerneront
les femmes et les hommes ce tir se
déroule à 50 mètres pour les adultes et
à une distance réduite pour les jeunes
l'entrée est libre
c'est la fin de ce sept huit week-ends
je vous retrouve lundi prochain pour les
7-8 sport excellent week-end sur tv fil